several local teens speaking out about
what the Boys and Girls Clubs have done
for them the touching moments on display
during the 2023 Youth of the Year Awards
one will go on as the Southern Nevada
Youth Of The Year a special night for
the Boys and Girls Clubs of Southern
Nevada I hope I
[Laughter]
hope there is a chance to highlight a
new generation of leaders I'm just in
awe of what they're able to do at their
age that's what's so remarkable the Ford
Las Vegas finalists recently gathered
for the announcement of the 2023 winner
I want people to know what the Boys and
Girls Club has to offer and what it did
to change my life and the things I'm
trying to do today
this leadership development program and
competition begins with an essay read in
front of judges about what the clubs
mean to them touching people's hearts is
what I try to achieve they've helped me
learn leadership skills they've helped
me make new friends and they've helped
me experience new things that I could
never even dreamed of it's the
consistency of our staff that really
provides those great Futures the
finalists shared how they were able to
overcome obstacles and transcend
challenges anytime I walked in I always
walked out a better person that's where
I teach you throughout the valley how to
cope with their mental health and why
they matter because they do these
finalists credited the 13 area clubs
with leading them on a path to a
brighter better future Seattle U was the
goal I plan on attending University with
my closest friend Aaliyah and welcoming
new experiences that I could have never
even dreamed of if it weren't for the
club as a whole it's an IB you are our
youth of the year
Anaya now goes on to represent southern
Nevada in state and National
competitions it's an immense honor and I
really appreciate that I was given the
opportunity to do that after telling
myself all these years that I could do
it and I'm finally achieving it and it
feels amazing and the good work of our
local Boys and Girls Clubs continues the
clubs are four walls and a ceiling it's
who we put in these clubs and the
day-to-day work that they do to you know
deal with the ups and the Downs
throughout childhood and I plan to just
give what back give back what was given
to me positivity and love
the winners and finalists of this year's
awards were 15 and 16 years old each of
them received a one thousand dollar
academic scholarship from Charles Schwab
for their accomplishments even more for
the winner and we wish them all great
luck with their future endeavors